منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وحتى ساعه متاخره
من الليل تزدحم زوايا الكورنيش بالقادمين
من مختلف دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي اضافه
الى العراقيين القادمين للمحافظات العراق
كافه احمد الرسام القادم من بغداد اتخذ من
الكورنيش مارسي ملح الحريه ان شاء الله
بغداد
تحول هذا الشارع البصري الى ساحه
للاحتفالات والتجمعات تجسد شعار خليجنا
واحد هنا اعلام سعوديه واخرى كويتيه
وقطريه
يتوسطها علم العراق
في تجنيف فرغ موسيقيه يعني في شغلات حلوه
جدا
احنا قاعدين نقول يا جماعه والله عندي
مكان انا في غصب ولا تروح معي الا تجيء
معي شيء غريب عجيب
رغم الاجواء المطيره وعدم وجود مباريات
هذا اليوم في البصره الا ان مئات الجماهير
العراقيه والخليجيه لا زالت تتوافدوا على
كورنيش شط العرب للمشاركه في هذا
الكرنفالي المستمري منذ اسبوعين
سامر الكبيسي العربيه